what is home to us is it just a location
on the map all the people we grew up
with or maybe it's the community we
belong to we want to know European
Commission is inviting you aspiring
video artists to show us what makes you
proud to be a European so the task is
simple choose an important event in the
history of the European Union using our
video archives and compare it to what it
meant for you and how it affected your
personal life
hey remember how on the same day of the
European Council meeting you were having
dinner with your Erasmus friends sharing
several dishes from everyone's country
or how on the same day Bureau was
declared we stuck with notes from 20
different countries don't hesitate to
use your personal stories as long as
they can be plated to the values of the
EU
human rights democracy free movement or
whatever you're proud of most the three
winners of the contest will be granted
with major cash rewards pretty cool huh
so what are you waiting for show us how
being a European has changed your life
we are Europe every day